[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes
brought to you by spectator tv and
broadcast on thursday the 20th of may
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show despite the uk's
impressive vaccine rollout the indian
variant is putting next month's freedom
day in doubt as cases have risen in
bolton bedford and blackburn
how should we respond i'll be joined by
professor christina pagel director of
ucl's clinical operational research unit
if there is a delay to unlocking on the
21st of june how will tori backbenchers
react
katie balls will explain trade tensions
created by the brexit deal are also on
the government's mind
james forsyth interviews former brexit
negotiator david frost in this week's
magazine
was ditching the backstop really a good
idea
then we'll look at the cover story for
this week's magazine tick tock intifada
how is social media worsening global
conflict
we'll be joined by journalist james ball
and seth franzman a middle east analyst
and journalist in jerusalem what is it
like to be a war correspondent
we'll hear from author judith mackerel
and cnn's clarissa ward
and finally prince harry said the first
amendment is bonkers
is he right and how has that gone down
we'll hear from freddie gray
all that to come in the next hour before
we get going if you enjoy what we do on
spectator tv then subscribe to our
youtube channel
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode and if
you want to subscribe to the magazine we
have a special offer for you
get 12 issues of the magazine plus a 20
pound amazon voucher for just 12 pounds
if it sounds too good to be true that's
because it is go to spectator.co.uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
now first covet case rates in bolton are
more than 10 times the english average
in bedford more than six the indian
variant of covet has been rising in
these areas leading to fears that the uk
could go the way of india
which saw a surge of cases resulting in
the dwindling of medical supplies
and hospitals being overrun it's this
new strain which is thought to have
contributed to the virus getting out of
control
with outstanding questions about its
transmissibility
although of course problems with india's
vaccine rollout have played a major role
as well
so the question today is could that
happen here and are we going to see the
uk's long-awaited freedom day put on
hold
to discuss i'm joined now by ucl's
professor christina pagel
christina thank you for joining us on
spectator tv
we've gotten a sense over the past 24 to
48 hours that the prime minister and his
officials think concerns over the indian
variant
may have been a false alarm but you
disagree
i don't think we know yet whether it was
a a false alarm
or not um certainly cases are still
going up
quite significantly and the latest data
from the uk covid con
genetics consortium which sequences data
here
shows that it's about 35 of all cases
now sequenced
is this new variant um the welcome
sanger data which was released
on monday which updates weekly and just
takes community cases so remove stasis
from travel and surge testing
are up to 28 of cases so there's no
doubt that it's been going up now the
question is
is growth slowing are the measures that
they put in place working
and as we get more cases do we get a
better handle on how much more
transmissible it is and it is very
sensitive
to it so i think there is agreement that
it's more transmissible than the
dominant
what's called the kent variant in the uk
but um it's kind of if it's only 10 more
then there probably won't be a big issue
this summer but if it's 50
more that could be a really big issue so
until we pin that down i think it's too
early to say whether it's a false alarm
so i've seen figures that say that the
indian variant is roughly 20
of the cases across england there you
cited 35
if it were significantly transmissible
or if we were in danger of seeing
exponential growth
why wouldn't this be reflected in the
national data
when actually it remains the case that
we're around 97
percent below the peak of cases and
deaths 99
below the peak yeah so that that 20
figure comes from the um cog the covet
genetics consortium website but that's
over the last two weeks
and so two weeks ago it was 15 and then
it went up to 30
so that's kind of the average of both of
them so over the last week it has gone
up further
um the reason cases have still been
going down is because the dominant
variant
so the kent variant that has been
declining and so effectively you've had
two epidemics you've had one
where cases are going down and one which
starting from much smaller numbers is
going up
and that's masking the rise of the
indian variant we saw exactly the same
thing in europe
in january and february when our variant
was becoming dominant there
and the old variant was dying out that
actually cases were coming down
even while the kent variant was
increasing so the question is
can we can we delay the increase of this
variant long enough
and vaccinate enough people so that we
can we can actually continue opening or
not
and we just and i don't think we know
that yet so we're not yet at the
situation where this variant is dominant
in england and until it is you wouldn't
expect it to start driving overall
numbers
but we have the vast vast majority of
the most vulnerable in the uk
vaccinated we now have 34 35 year olds
getting vaccinated well over 20
million people have their second jab so
in terms of those who would have been
vulnerable last year when the
circumstances were different we're in
very different
territory now and cases are still at
rock bottom
hospitalizations deaths as well what's
the reason for not pushing ahead with
opening up
well it's certainly true i mean like the
vaccines are great
and if we didn't have the vaccine
program we would be in a situation that
india is facing right now or nepal is
facing right now where they're seeing
you know terrible surges and hospitals
overfilling and
and people dying on the streets now
we're not in that situation and that is
because of our vaccine program
but if you have a variable and this is
what the sage modeling subgroup shows
this is you know this
the government's own scientific advisors
show that if you have a variant
that is that is 50 more transmissible
even if the vaccines work just as well
as they do now even if you have really
high uptake which we do that's all in
the model
you can still get to a situation where
you overwhelm hospitals
and that's just because if you have an
incredibly large number of people
infected
even a tiny percentage that then gets
sick and the vaccines aren't purpose
even three
three four percent is still enough to
create to create stress on the nhs now
if it's just 20 or 30 more transmissible
you're not going to see
that level so that's kind of why it's
really really important that we pin down
exactly how much more transmissible it
is
and we're told that we're going to have
that data in the coming weeks but one of
the issues that we have had over the
course of the pandemic
is that a lot of the modeling that's
taken place within sage within
government
has been based on worst case scenarios
and the lab data and real world data
that we continue to get
shows that the vaccines are far more
effective than often the modeling takes
into account
i know that you've been quite cautious
and nervous about the reopening that's
taken place so far
and certainly around the 21st of june
but if all the data continues to point
in the right direction
would there be any reason not to go
ahead with it so firstly the latest
stage modelings are not based on worst
case scenarios they use
up-to-date data from public health
england and the latest published
information and the new england journal
and the science you know
in science on vaccine efficacy they
assume
very very high vaccine fiscal efficacy
that comes directly
from our data they assume very high
vaccine uptake
which comes directly from our data and
it's because that data is better than
was expected in february march that
their models are actually showing
um a much more limited search so under
the old under the kent variant if we
didn't have this new variant
their models are showing actually we
probably would be fine to open this
summer
because they're using actual real data
they're not modeling a worst case
scenario right now
now the new variant does change things
um if
it comes to you know three weeks time
and cases are still going down
overall then yes i think we're in a
situation where you can say okay the new
variants turned out
not to be as bad as we feared we're in a
position where we can open further but
we don't know that yet because we're not
there yet
so that's that's all i'm saying i'm
saying you know we can't promise where
we're going to be in a few
a few weeks because that data's not here
yet
well i don't think anyone can promise
anything um over the course of this
pandemic we know that the virus
continues to
surprise us but as we're not expected to
do the next phase of reopening until the
21st of june
where do you really differ from the
government's projected timelines and
policies for reopening um
why did i say i differed what i differ
in
is saying that that we can we can
put a date on it and i don't think we
should say that the 21st of june is a
special date and that if we miss it it's
a big disaster
but i think where where i differ most on
at two things one is international
travel
and our border policy so you know we saw
that in january and february we were
very focused on um
on the brazilian and the south african
variants you know that
the variants that were discovered there
and
we kind of had a red list and thought
that would keep them out and we
certainly have controlled those variants
in the uk they're very very low levels
and we just and then it turned out that
the next dangerous variant came from
india
we don't know where the next dangerous
variant is coming from covert is still
um running rampant in many countries
across the world
and many of them don't sequence right
and so it's not until too late that we
understand that there's a new barrier
that's arisen so i think this summer
while we're still
trying to finish vaccinating our
population is not the right summer to
have international travel
and risk new importations um the other
thing you say it's a
you say it's a dangerous variant but the
evidence
hasn't quite held that up yet i mean all
of the lab
and real-world date real-world data that
we're getting about the variant would
suggest that vaccines
hold up against it and covet has mutated
many of thousands of times
so at what point do you think it would
be safe to open up the borders more and
to resume some kind of normal
international travel
is it about vaccination numbers is it
about covered levels when i said that it
is dangerous it is dangerous because it
is more transmissible
and that and that makes it harder to
keep covered under control there's no
there's no doubt that even if it's just
10 percent more transmissible
we would be in a better position if it
wasn't here i mean
well indeed we'd be in a much better
position if we didn't
have the final evidence like the the the
deputy chair of jcvi the government's
vaccination subcommittee
he said that actually it does resist the
vaccines more
than the kent variant now it seems to
protect against severe illness but you
can get sick and you can pass it on if
you're vaccinated now
what that means is that it's even it
makes it more transmissible right
because it means that you can pass it on
even if you don't personally get sick
we don't know what impact that will have
on long covered
we don't know if it will mutate further
given
given the the the opportunities here so
so i think
saying that any new variant that is
fitter than the last variant is a
dangerous occurrence
is true most mutations don't become
fitter they die out this one is not
dying out it's dominating in india it's
dominating in nepal
in every country it's been discovered
it's growing rapidly so it's kind of
it's the next kent variant if you like
now if we're lucky
it won't be fit enough to overcome our
vaccination program
covid is a dangerous virus variants
included
but we now see that cases are
decelerating or even declining in the
major outbreaks in the uk
cases also appear to be leveling off in
india
to go back to that original question
given the fact that we may be living
with variants
for years to come and indeed
indefinitely at what point would you say
you think we can start to resume
some normality when it comes to
international travel and perhaps some of
those
bigger decisions around large-scale
events and the complete removal of
social distancing
if this is something we're likely to
have to live with for a long time
i would like us to follow israel's
example where they
only opened up once they fully
vaccinated
and we're only about 35 fully vaccinated
of adults fully vaccinated um
about 75 80 of all adults in israel and
they're now vaccinating
adolescents um and they're the only
country that's actually achieved
control of kovitz to almost zero levels
through vaccination
other countries with high vaccination
rates are still seeing all about it
because they haven't got to that level
yet and israel closed its borders
entirely
while it was doing its vaccination
program and even now
has quite straight border controls and
even now still asks people to wear masks
inside and has masks inside schools
but they are reaping the benefits
because they've managed to open their
economy almost entirely
without seeing any kind of resurgence of
cable so that's what i would like to see
i'd like to see us get to the stage
where we have
vaccinated maybe 80 85 of all adults
fully
and have a plan for how we potentially
boost against variance and vaccinate
adolescents
and that should be by september it's not
that far away right
and i think so for me 2022
let's open right that's fine you know
we'll know a lot more about variance
we'll have new vaccines
most of our population will be protected
we hopefully will be at least near the
threshold where you can rely on
population immunity to keep new
outbreaks low
and contained so that that's how i see
it
when you say let's open obviously the
opening process is phased
would you in your ideal scenario be
rolling back some of the reopening we've
done would you pause it here
or would you just continue to follow the
data in whichever direction it took us
i think i'd follow the data i mean at
the moment um
if it was up to me i would have delayed
monday's reopening
by a few weeks um until until we
actually did know more about this
variant now i think it's too late to
roll it back
um but i'll be watching the data really
carefully
and if it turns out it's fine then then
okay then we keep going
you know i'm not i'm not saying that
that in in falling cases we should
have more restrictions but i do think
that the data is there to be concerned
right now and there are perfectly
reasonable explanations for why we're
not seeing
um an overall increase because we don't
have this variant being dominant yet
and we we're in a situation where one
variant's falling and the other fairy is
going up and they and they haven't
overtaken each other yet
back in early april you also warned
about the 12th of april reopening
telling the independent that we are
seeing the same things we saw last year
and in the autumn
none of the fundamentals have changed
but of course we saw schools reopen
shops outdoor hospitality more
households mixing outdoors
of course it's too early to say what the
17th of may reopening is going to do
but we just have not seen that national
surge in infection hospitalizations or
death
the opposite in fact so would you agree
that now that the fundamentals
have changed and that they are looking
more positive i never said that we were
going to have a surge in infections and
hospitalizations from
from that reopening and in fact the sage
models from february march said that the
dangerous step was the step we've just
taken in may not the one in april
what i said what did you mean by the
fundamentals i've said that there have
been an
increase in cases in march in schools we
didn't we haven't seen that today
since april and i suspect that's because
community transmission actually did drop
a lot over easter which is really good
news
and we were quite lucky in that we had
quite nice easter weather so people
could go outside
but we are now seeing where cases are
going up so in bolton
cases in school-aged children are higher
than they've ever been in the pandemic
they're
you know over 500 cases per hundred
thousand per week
so it's not the case that everything's
always fine
when i we're talking about the
fundamentals what hasn't changed is that
even now
people are being asked to do rapid tests
that people are being asked to test
themselves all the time but there's no
real support for you
if you test positive there's very little
financial support and so little
financial incentive for people to get
tested if they can't afford to then
isolate at home
it's also very disruptive to your to
your life to carrying responsibilities
to school
and so we are seeing that in
disadvantaged communities they are less
likely to come forward for testing and
less likely to isolate and have higher
rates of coverage
exposure through work and poorer housing
so we are seeing that there is this
disparity
between more well-off areas and less
well-off areas and so what worries me
then and worries me now is that actually
what we'll see is the covert becomes a
disease that's very associated with
poverty and disadvantage and i think
that could be avoided
by providing more support to those
communities i suppose the difficult
thing is that
lockdowns um regardless of of what you
think of them
um level down um in in in the most
serious sense and we know that they
affect
the poor and the disadvantage the most
and it just comes down to that
very difficult trade-off doesn't it
about protecting people from the virus
you mentioned children there but also of
course the 20 000 children that we know
have
dropped out of school since lockdowns
hit
yeah i mean like no one no one thinks
lockdown is a good idea
and through good public health measures
you should be able to avoid lockdowns
now
when you get a situation where the virus
is increasing exponentially
that we had um in december for instance
and that you know india's just had and
other countries just had
and you have a situation where your
hospitals are overwhelmed and an
independent report that came out
yesterday said that actually yes the nhs
was overwhelmed
in january it means that no one can
access care in the way that you would
want them to access now that disrupts
your economy
it disrupts people's lives if you feel
like i'm not in a position to be able
to get care if i get sick it's going to
restrict your behaviors and so you do
then end up having to have these
lockdowns and the more it gets out of
control the longer you have to look down
for
to get cases back down again whereas if
you prevent cases going up in the first
place
it's much more effective and that's been
you know
my advice the whole time is if you
actually did for instance support people
to isolate
then effectively all you're doing is
locking down people most likely to have
covid for a short period of time
letting the rest of the economy carry on
but we've never really done that
so we've ended up kind of opening and in
the cycle of restrictions and no
restrictions restrictions and no
restrictions i don't think that's
optimal health policy
and i never have but i do think that
when you have a virus that goes out of
control
and overwhelms your hospitals and your
health care
and actually affects the disadvantaged
communities much more who had rates of
covid you know twice three times the
most advantaged areas and suffered much
more
death and disability from it that that's
the problem and you have to deal with it
christina thank you for joining
spectator tv
now before we get into our next segment
a reminder that you can subscribe to our
youtube channel to make sure you never
miss an episode of spectator tv
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon to make
sure you don't miss out
now to discuss the government's thinking
on the indian variant i'm joined by
katie balls our deputy political editor
and james forsyth our political editor
katie in this week's politics column for
the magazine you shed light on the
debate taking place in government over
the 21st of june reopening
talk us through it so i think there had
been a point last week
when there was a sense in number 10 that
they preparing for a good news
announcement
uh to be next week um that the june 21st
easing would go ahead but this plan was
derailed
by a rise in community transmission of
the indian
variant as it's been coming to be known
of covid in parts of the north
west including bolton and since then the
prime minister vote publicly be drawn on
whether that date will go ahead
and you've got plenty of sage scientists
i'm happy to fill the airwaves with
concerns
and also some anonymous briefings coming
out of one suggesting
um as revealed by robert pester on
coffee house that the chances of all
restrictions going now by the june 21st
is ultimately close to nil what's really
going on
well i think what's interesting is
speaking to people in government
the strong consensus is that no one
really knows what's going wrong
um going on and that means that i think
going forward we have a situation where
the prime minister i think is quite keen
to press on if you can i think that in
recent days
um actually numbers have been fairly
assured or calmed by some of the data
coming in
and that perhaps the indian variant
isn't as transmissible as first seen
and they will be able to press on but
we're not going to know for sure
i think for several weeks but we should
have i think an indicator by next week
as to where this really is looking like
it's going to shape out to be a big
problem
or so long as things keep going this way
things should be okay in terms of the
easing
you mentioned some positive data there
you say in the
column that boris johnson himself thinks
that the scientists
might be overly worried yet over the
course of the pandemic the prime
minister tends to follow their lead
albeit later than they would often like
do you think pressure is mounting
yes and i think we have seen that
pattern which is why you have to take a
pinch of salt if the prime minister is
you know
insisting it's going to go ahead and
he's not even doing anything as bold as
that
we are in a different place now in terms
of the vaccination program and i think
what's interesting
is speaking to ministers and tory mps i
think it's very difficult politically
for the prime minister to push
back june 21st or even water it down in
a
major way um if the vaccines work if the
vaccines work
i think there is little political space
for him and so far everything is
suggesting they do work against the
indian strain
so i think unless we start to see the
data going in an obviously bad way which
is a link to hospital admissions
i think he's going to come under a lot
of pressure from both his cabinet
um not everyone is cabinet but i would
say a large chunk of them and
particularly as parliamentary party to
press ahead
um given the government has made so much
of its vaccine program
you know they see it as you know one of
the few things they did right in this
pandemic
i've had mps say to me that were they to
now delay things
it would be snatching defeat from the
jewels of victory the thing to look out
for however
is that there may now be a push to get
your various changes in on the covered
plan
i think one strong push is on
international travel so
ministers i think including matt hancock
believe that clamping down
on international travel even more will
help maintain domestic freedom
well come back to the cabinet and their
thoughts but james
first what are the government's options
around the 21st of june
is there a scenario where they can
credibly claim freedom day but
realistically there's still a lot of
restrictions in place
yeah so i think all the focus on the
date of the 21st of june
misses the fact that you could have two
very different types for 21st of june
one time the 21st of june uh sees the
working from home
guidance go masks go everywhere but
public transport
and crucially the one meter rule go
allowing
uh pubs and restaurants to operate at
kind of full capacity
another version of june 21st is much
more cautious you keep the one meter
rule
uh so that's you know table service only
in pubs
restaurants not full uh you still
require
masks everywhere where they are
currently required
and you carry on encouraging people to
work from home and avoid
public transport if they can i mean
those are
there is a spectrum of options for june
21st i i i would agree with katie's
analysis
i think that uh at the end of last week
i think there was a sense
almost that the best the government
could hope for was that kind of
latter version of june 21st so the the
limit on
numbers might go but all of these other
restrictions would remain in place i
think there is
now beginning to be some very soto voce
cautious optimism that they might be
able to get closer
to that that kind of first version of
june 21st i think that's partly because
uh the early signs are that the vaccines
don't lose efficacy against uh
the the indian variant and also
that i think people in whitehall are
watching the hospital data from places
like bolton
like hawks and at the moment they are
not seeing that the increase in cases
there
is filtering through into an increase in
hospitalizations
which would suggest that uh the
vaccine has done its job uh and
particularly the vaccination of the
vulnerable has done its job in breaking
the link
between cases and hospitalizations
there's also a sense that while uh the
indian variant is rising quickly uh
surge tensing was sent to a whole
slew of more local authority areas on uh
on wednesday
uh it might it the initial worry was it
might be up to 50 percent more
transmissible
i think the sense now is but the number
is probably quite a bit below that now
if it dropped back down to 20 more
transmissible than the kent variant for
example
uh that would that would lead a narrow
path
open to getting to that that more
genuine freedom day of june 21st
james covid isn't the only thing on the
government's mind for the magazine this
week you interviewed david frost
former brexit negotiator and now cabinet
office minister
responsible for handling the european
union how's that going
well i don't think anyone could describe
uk eu relations as
good at the moment earlier this month
you had kind of royal navy
ship scrambled to a fishing dispute off
jersey
and the northern ireland protocol is
obviously a kind of constant tension
between the uk
and the eu i think david frost in this
interview
was trying to say to the eu you know if
we can't get
some of the things we want we are
prepared to trigger
article 16 of the northern ireland
protocol which allows one side to
unilaterally set the protocol
it's very struck how he talked about uh
how the trade boundary which is his
description of the so-called border in
the rhc
has had more of a trade
more of a chilling effect than expected
and has created more diversion of trade
than expected
that use of the phrase diversion of
trade i think is important because
that is one of the reasons the sides can
give
for triggering article 16 of the
protocol which allows one side to
unilaterally
set it aside finally katie sticking on
trade there have been
issues this week with one of the uk's
flagship post-brexit trade deals
with australia what's happening there
yes we are seeing a return of what i
think have
now now quite widely known as the
waitrose protectionists and cabinet
um against uh the free marketeers
perhaps the little free marketers
and and this is ultimately liz trust who
is the international trade secretary and
i think
uh her department are fairly close to
signing off in australia trade deal
um but certain forces in the cabinet and
certainly the
farmers union do not like uh the idea of
australian meat coming into the uk
market
and that is now getting kicked back
within cabinet this is michael gove and
george eustis
the environment secretary who are the
ones opposing and david frost who we've
just been talking about is one of liz
truster's allies
and this has led to a general row
about you know what is what is the uk's
aim of brexit
is it free trade deals in which case uh
the australia trade deal
i think is one that you would need to do
if you can't do an australia trade deal
it's hard to see
what other ones really you would do with
this free trade agenda
um or is it to uh protect farmers
interests and i think one of the things
making it slightly harder for number 10
is the fact that those pushing against
this deal are saying it would
particularly hurt farmers in wales and
scotland
um so that would be an issue because it
would damage the union
but generally speaking i think that when
it comes to the prime minister and
number 10 they lean
more towards the trust camp they're
quite supportive boris johnson does
think that
one of the main reasons for brexit was
to push for free trade deals
and therefore i think it's more likely
or not that she will come through
uh victorious in this one and the trader
will be more to her liking
than those on the other side and james
when it comes to the standoff of the
waitrose protectionists you've written
on coffeehouse this week that their
national
national security implications this as
well as it relates to china can you
explain
yeah china became australia's largest
trading partner
uh but then when the australian
government started calling for an
independent inquiry into the origins of
coronavirus
you know the chinese tried to use that
economic relationship to kind of
pressure australia to take a different
stance and
you know that's resulted in huge tariffs
being slapped on australian wine and
barley
uh bureaucratic reasons given for not
accepting
uh australian beef or australian timber
and and so i think for the uk to not do
a tradie of australia in these
circumstances would make a mockery of
the uk's claims to be trying to
encourage
you know democratic solidarity against
beijing and
i also think that you know the global
message then if a uk
can't do a trade deal with a fellow
anglophone country
would be pretty poor i also think some
of the concerns about farmers and
farmers are
overblown because you know even if you
think that australian
meat imports to china i have taken a
permanent hit from this dispute
that the asian market for meat with the
rise of the asian middle class
um is still growing rapidly and beef
commands a higher price in asia than it
does here
i also think that um and so i think
that's where australian farmers will
continue to concentrate on exporting
indeed
if you are talking about who is
potentially most at risk from this deal
it is probably the irish who export over
half of their
beef production to the uk and and
generally dominate
uh the the cheaper end of the market
that that is probably the exports that
are threatened because you know
they are now having they would now if
this deal went through in the form of
this trust once
they were now having to be compete with
the australians on on kind of
level terms um and i don't think
considering where
uh what where with the the normal price
point at which british beef is competing
but this deal is the threat that people
think it is um
i also think that uh the uk wants to do
a deal with new zealand you're gonna
have a similar issue but i think it's
really worth noting that
even today new zealand does not send
the uk its full uh uh
tariff quota allowance of lamb so i
think the
only idea that this country is about to
be flooded with uh
cheap australian and uh new zealand meat
it is massively overdone
thank you james and thank you katie now
to the cover story of this week's
magazine
tick tock intifada journalist james ball
is the author of the piece
arguing that social media is inflaming
international tension
in the israel-palestine conflict for
instance videos shared on tik-tok
encourage violence and spread
disinformation
james joins me now with seth fransman a
middle east analyst and journalist based
in jerusalem
james in this week's cover piece you say
that tick tock and social media
inflame global conflict the most recent
example of this violence is in israel
and palestine
what role has it played there i think
for a while we've known that there's the
potential for social media to
inflame sort of ongoing tensions just
through making them really sorry
just through making them more visible
and sort of really evoking emotions
obviously if people can see
firsthand the aftermath of an attack
or something like that it really gives
the immediacy
what we're seeing sort of move into it
that's a bit new and a bit
escalating is that sort of in the run-up
to the tensions that led to
the sort of latest bounce of conflict in
gaza
um was there seemed to be a tick-tock
trend around
um assaulting uh visibly jewish people
there was quite a viral video
of a man being assaulted by two
teenagers on public transport
and these sort of challenges against a
sort of already tense
backdrop seemed to really uh
add fuel to the fire in country
and then what's happened as as the
conflict sort of broken out
is even people who don't seek out
anything on
israel palestine who've never thought
about the issue never engaged with it
suddenly see it in their tick-tock feeds
in their twitter feeds on facebook
and it really sort of escalates things
it makes it
harder for either side to back down even
if they wanted to
james why is tick tock becoming the
popular place to share this
horrible kind of thing you can post
videos on twitter
facebook instagram so why is this the
platform
um it's difficult to sort of say i don't
think it is the only one i think this is
happening on every platform but
tick tock's the new one and the one that
has the youngest user base and so
it's often people's introduction to
politics
um it also seems to be
sort of perhaps the most tilted in one
direction
um you can sort of go quite quickly on
tick-tock
on its discovery page from looking at
what you would usually do
and it's got lots of you know diet pill
type stuff it's got inspirational baking
it's got makeup tutorials
and you can jump to that to then
suddenly a very jarring
sort of depiction of violence in in gaza
um just because of what's working on the
content and the strange rights algorithm
works
i think one thing that's become notable
on tick tock is
its jewish users now just cannot escape
the issue um in a way that's really
kind of not okay people who have no
connection to israel have never lived in
israel have never
sort of expressed support for the
actions of israel's government
and are doing a video about something
totally unrelated
we'll just find all of their reactions
and responses are free palestine
um just as we don't think it's
acceptable to hold say
a british muslim accountable for what
the state of saudi arabia does
there really is problems inherent in
that kind of
response and we are seeing quite a lot
of that on techsoc
seth you're in jerusalem can you give us
an update on what's happening right now
yeah i think there is an attempt now to
achieve a ceasefire between
israel and hamas but there has also been
so far i think on by day 11 a total of 4
000 rockets fired and
there was an attack on a bus this
morning a military bus near the gaza
strip by an anti-tank missile
then we've had sirens around the gaza
strip but i think up into ashkelon so
it does appear that you know hamas will
try to
continue firing rockets and achieve
attacks right up until whatever
ceasefire is broken
so that they can claim that they kind of
won and i think that's what we'll see
um there has been a relatively let's say
quiet eight or ten hours and i don't
think there's been a lot of airstrikes
by israel as well so
it remains to be seen if by friday uh
the conflict may end
seth what we're seeing on social media
is a growing but not necessarily new
phenomenon
can you talk to us about the history of
social media in middle east conflicts
i know it was used notably in the 2011
arab spring for example
yeah i mean i think that social media
certainly helped to transform the middle
east in terms of giving lots of people
um you know a decade a half ago a lot
more of a voice average people
i think though there was a change you
know after the arab spring in which you
also saw a lot of social media used by
isis
and extremists so that you know i
remember back in 2014 you know people
were just publishing
beheading videos and stuff it was people
were putting the most graphic content on
and they say that when twitter and
facebook went to remove
uh pro isis accounts you know they had
to remove millions of them so
there was a huge amount of extremist
content so actually
what was supposed to be a positive thing
for people to you know protest
against authoritarian regimes actually
became instead of something that helps
people or
achieves coexistence i would say that it
helped to radicalize large numbers of
people
and actually it enabled something like
50 000 people from around the world to
come join
isis because they were able usually to
coordinate initially on social media and
then they were able to use other things
like whatsapp or whatever but
they that's how many of them it seemed
to be able to actually physically were
able to come
so i think that is a very bad phenomenon
you could almost
argue that uh the explosion in the use
of social media helped to contribute to
the isis genocide and i think that
if you go back to the era of bin laden
remember he used to produce like tapes
and stuff that were
were prov handed out one to one you know
you can't radicalize as many people if
you're if you're distributing tapes
uh you can do it a lot faster if you're
using um you know a platform that gives
you access to millions of people so i
think that
unfortunately we've seen that social
media in a strange way
radicalized and made people more
sectarian and now of course you know the
big organizations or corporations that
run it have tried to then
you know i think in a kind of arbitrary
ham handed manner
you know try to cut off little pieces
here and here like oh let's get rid of
isis accounts let's get rid of the
radical right that's fine
but there isn't a lot of a systematic
thought put into it i think we
so we've we've come to a point now where
even states
in the region like turkey or other
places you know will try to
try to get the companies actually to
remove content that they don't agree
with
or they pass laws for instance that will
make it so you for instance can't post
certain things if you're in certain
countries you know
i think that is unfortunately turning us
into a bit of an orwellian world so it's
a
it's totally the opposite of what we
thought social media was going to be
doing
but that also is you know kind of the
onus i guess is on the average person
because
it's a hobbesian world people are not
necessarily good so
social media in some ways just catered
uh to the loudest worst voices because
we're just i mean we're generally used
to the fact that
the average normal nice person just
doesn't have a megaphone so i think that
that's something we saw a lot in the
middle east unfortunately
james can you talk us through the
psychology of posting these videos to
social media in the first place
you would think that posting such a
graphic horrible video to a platform
like tiktok would lose you support
not help you gain support i think
there's sometimes sort of the the shock
of the new people want to feel
engaged um people might not want to
watch a traditional news show
but you know i think gen z gets quite
patronized if people suggest they're not
into news or they're only into
minor stuff and so part of it is a
desire to sort of show that you're
taking things seriously
but also the sort of key tone of a good
social post as well as kind of tugging
on emotions
is trying to sort of explain something
that the mainstream isn't telling you
now that can often be the full-on
conspiratorial
q anom stuff that we tend to see on
facebook actually on youtube more than
tick tock
but it can also be a hey but what
they're not telling you is this was
actually a colonial settle
settlement to do x y or zed and that
sort of
you know networked informal kind of
thing
sort of helps pull people in it helps
sort of build a community it helps get a
bit of
credo people like to feel knowing
and so it sort of does appeal
to people it's you know it's it's good
cause it's a good protest cause
um and sort of young adults in every
generation have always wanted those
um and of course it does attach to a
real
serious political movement um it's just
often the way people social introduces
people to it
can be quite strange and it should be
said there is quite a lot of
outright misinformation um on both
on actually pro-israel and pro-palestine
accounts you know people reusing old
videos people kind of knowingly
misleading um including some people tied
to ministries
so it's it's really a mess out there
seth finally um to follow on from
james's point
and point you were making before when
you were saying that actually in many
ways in the past social media has been
used as a
force for good um how do you weigh it up
now
with these kinds of videos going around
with the disinformation
do you think social media has been a
force for good when it comes to
political matters
um i don't know if it's necessarily a
force for good but i mean it's just it
is it's
it's a force it's a medium right i mean
i don't know if radio
or tv or necessarily or print media have
always been a force for good i mean it's
a nature of
it's the nature of a platform so i just
think it exists i think that it can do
good i think when you have a conflict
you know you obviously tend to then
emphasize all the worst
attributes of things because obviously
you know the
the worst scenes of children being
killed or what have you are going to be
posted even if they're fake but it
doesn't matter that's the kind of thing
that's going to be
passed around but i think look after the
abraham accords last year when there was
peace between israel and some of the
gulf states
you know social media played a huge role
i think in terms of amongst
a small group of people of posting you
know
stories about coexistence and hanukkah
and join shared holidays so
you know it can also be a place that
lots of people meet i mean i think
that's one positive aspect so
when there is when there is a kind of
positive wind blowing of peace and
things like that
then you can see it definitely as a
force for good so i think it's just it
also just depends maybe on what
what kind of controversy or what kind of
you know political climate there is at
the time
thank you james and thank you seth so
what is it like to actually report from
the front line of a conflict
clarisse award is cnn's chief
international correspondent
and has covered places like iraq
afghanistan and syria
she joins me now alongside judith
mackerel author of going with the boys
a book tracking the lives of six female
war correspondents
as they reported on the second world war
judith clarissa thank you for joining me
on spectator tv
judith your book going with the boys
gives insight into the experiences of
female correspondents reporting from the
front lines of world war
ii what was their experience like well
like any
uh war correspondence dealing with
conflicts today
it was a mix of extraordinary
exhilaration
extraordinary terror boredom
and frustration but for these women too
it was
it was a very particular era because as
well as
battling with all the issues of being on
the front line
they were also actually having to battle
to earn the right
to report in the first place because um
certainly at the outbreak of world war
ii
all women journalists were expected to
be were expected to report from the home
front and essentially to do soft women's
stories about
hospitals about evacuation shelters
about
women working in munitions factories
they weren't
expected to be right in the middle of
the thick of battle
and the struggles that
they fought to both get the military to
persuade the military and their
press editors to give them permission to
report
was was essentially very much central to
their experience
but as i write i think the fact that
for several years they had to use their
own ingenuity
martha galcon for instance riding
stairway on a hospital ship
in order to cover the d-day landings
because
women were not allowed it often meant
that they had a very different color and
a very different heartbeat
to their stories clarissa to compare and
contrast what is it like today
i mean it's so you know it's so
interesting hearing due to talk about
that because you see
how much progress has been made um an
extraordinary amount
there are a huge number of women like
myself on the front lines doing this
kind of reporting
um and i think for the most part we are
treated with equality and sometimes i
even think we have an advantage
in some conservative societies for
example we're able to get to places
that our male colleagues can't get to
and we're able to sit down
uh with women in their part of the house
and and tell their stories as well which
is
a real privilege and something that's
been absolutely lacking
uh from the sort of broader coverage of
war particularly
in conservative muslim societies for for
many many years
so i do think a lot has changed i don't
think it's always
completely changed um i do think that
there
are still elements of misogyny and
sexism and i do think that
you face um unique threats as well
potentially in conflict zones
as a woman but i am heartened to hear
um how how far i think we've come and
i'm also i think like many
other female war correspondents
profoundly inspired by the legacy of
those women who due to the describes
i was so interested when you said that
it was
easier often to get the stories of women
from these conflict zones as a woman but
also i think my women in world war ii
often found it was easy to get stories
from the men
that the soldiers would maybe confide
things to them about you know maybe
their more private hopes and fears and
terrors
and and also that because they often
assume that perhaps women didn't know so
much about
government and it's such a funny point
and it's one that i've made before as
well
which is that sometimes as women i i
used to joke that it's a wonderful thing
to be underestimated
right often we're underestimated but
also we're often seen as less of a
threat
and whether that's me just pretending to
be asleep as i go through a checkpoint
or whatever
it might be um it has been helpful to
have a woman
and you have hit on a really essential
point
which is that because you're seen often
as being less threatening
men are often more likely to open up to
you and i've particularly found that to
be the case when
i've been dealing with um militants or
jihadists
like doing the isis story i was able to
get
interviews and get to the sort of
the nub of the sort of personal element
of what was going on with some of these
western jihadis
in a way that my male colleagues really
struggle too because i was able to also
sit there and chat with them about like
what's your sister up to like what has
your wife do
you know and just have these more human
conversations
and not be seen automatically as you're
a mercenary
you're a spy you're a government soldier
judith did you find similarities in the
women that you profiled they must have
all been
incredibly courageous you mentioned
saint greed schultz who attended joseph
gerbel's propaganda screenings
but was secretly jewish yeah i mean
they obviously they they were all
insanely
brave um and insanely ambitious too
uh i think they came to the war maybe
from
different motivations seagree schultz
certainly had been in berlin
since 1913 and loved the city and was
utterly horrified by what was happening
under the
nazi regime for her continuing to
remain in the city and to report on
everything
for the chicago tribune you know risking
threats of interrogation
and worse that for her that was a hugely
moral
crusade um i think for martha gelhorn
too writing about the war from the point
of view of the suffering victims
the injustice of the the fascist powers
that that for her her
her thought that if she could change
public opinion if she could change the
world
that would sort of that justified every
single word that she wrote
um for some of the others some for
instance claire hollingworth
it was more a sense of
competitiveness the absolute
adrenaline of the scoop getting to the
headlines first
that essentially drove her and for
someone like virginia coles who
um was a kind of uh
hilariously rogue operator because for
years she would
turn up in trenches in high-heeled shoes
and lipstick
for her it was as much curiosity she was
just
thrilled to be seeing the world thrilled
to be expanding her own horizons
so within that essential ambitiousness
they
they had different motives but
interestingly to
although they would give each other
loyal support and friendship
when their paths crossed they didn't
care to be seen
as a sort of professional sisterhood
they they because they were they were
such a minority out in the field
and having to battle so hard to be taken
as seriously as men
they were quite reluctant to uh
to be presented as a kind of suffering
minority
to and they so they they looked they
looked out for each other but they were
very much
solo operators clarissa last question to
you i'd like to hear what you think on
this what qualities are needed to be a
war reporter
i think the first quality that's needed
honestly is curiosity
you have to be really curious you have
to be a good listener
because you have to be willing to hear
things that you're uncomfortable with
that challenge your own value systems
and you have to be willing to give
everyone a fair shake
and hear them out and um and and try to
understand
um any given conflict from from all
different perspectives
so that can really challenge us um
and particularly the way we think
nowadays we sometimes think that
listening is a weakness
um and then it means you're can sort of
conceding the moral high ground
um and then the other thing i would say
is that it does take um
resilience and i don't mean and i and i
hesitate to say bravery because i really
don't think of myself as being brave
but a big part of what we don't talk
about when we talk about covering war
although judith
uh you know sort of alluded to it there
is there's a lot of killing time and
boredom and waiting for things to happen
and
sleeping in rough spots and not having
proper food while you're
hoping that this operation is going to
get started or
the group that you're with is going to
get mobilized or you're waiting for
permissions and
and that's the kind of you know when
you're in the sort of heady excitement
of the moment
you'd be surprised how strong people can
be and they can and they can
see and experience a lot and and get
through it
the tough times sometimes to really get
through are those sort of
endless you know i remember sitting on
helipads for like 48
72 hours sometimes in iraq and 42 degree
heat
waiting for a chopper to take you out to
the operation that you were
trying to cover and so yeah if you're a
picky eater
or if you're super impatient um and you
struggle with that kind of stuff then
it's
it's probably not the career for you one
of the um
qualities that claire hollingworth
always prized herself on was being able
to sleep
anywhere yes and
uh there was a wonderful image of her
setting off to cover the
um italian invasion of greece um in 1940
and she arrives at the station
in the middle of nowhere there's a 40
now wait for the train there's one other
journalist
a guy who's kind of complaining away and
claire just takes a
swig of whiskey and lies down on the
cold stone platform and sleeps for 14
hours
and you know that as you say
is that it's that ability to to just
ride out
these really bleak tedious periods that
that i think made her in a way the most
doggedly successful of the six women in
my book
thank you clarissa and thank you judith
the first amendment in america
enshrines freedom of speech religion
assembly and the press
but speaking on a podcast last week
prince harry said that as he sort of
understood it it was
bonkers i'm joined now by the
spectator's deputy editor freddie gray
freddie you're a brit who's also spent a
lot of time in america
do you understand the first amendment
and do you think it's bonkers
well i've never quite got my head around
the american bill of rights so i suppose
i do think it's bonkers
in a way uh but while i'm pro-free
speech i'm not a free speech
absolutist i think when it comes to
royal families if you're going to have
a royal family they should not have
absolute freedom of speech
they should know when to keep their
mouths shut sadly
prince harry does not seem to know when
to keep his mouth shut
there's something a bit grating when you
think about the process through which
the first amendment came about to hear
royalty
criticizing those civil liberties but
maybe that gives us
insight into harry's thinking now
perhaps in his mind he isn't really a
prince anymore
like he once was well i dread to think
what's going on in his mind i think uh
he's sort of been brainwashed
by a kind of therapeutic culture and a
lot of people want to blame his wife for
that i'm not sure you can
i mean it's quite funny really because
when we launched the spectator in
america
we had a cover piece from rod little uh
begging americans to take
meghan markle back and now this week
um americans including our washington
editor amber athey are begging
britain to take prince harry back it's
it's an unhappy marriage
well perhaps they'll end up back in
canada
perhaps some of this explains their
feelings towards not all but
some of the press coverage of their
movements that harry just doesn't
actually understand
freedom of the press i don't think he
does
uh i don't think he understands a lot a
friend of mine made quite a good joke
that he thought harry was talking about
the second amendment the right to bear
arms but in fact he realized no harry
was talking about free speech
and and that sort of reflects quite what
people think about harry's intellect
it's it's limited
it's not particularly polite to say this
to a country that you've adopted but as
believers in the first amendment perhaps
we should forgive him you can forgive
him kate
uh i might okay jury's still out
uh and maybe harry should be spending a
bit more time on his own couples podcast
archwell
i know you're an avid listener freddie
but as i understand it they've only
released
one episode since its much hyped launch
last year
every five minutes i checked my spotify
feed to see if the next episode has
dropped and i'm constantly disappointed
well here's hoping they release a new
episode for you soon thank you freddie
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode why not subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and the bell icon
to make sure you never miss an episode
thank you for watching and do join us
again next week for the week in 60
[Music]
minutes
[Music]
you